evita en la historia nacional ha dejado
una impronta que hasta el día de hoy
no la puede la puede observar nosotros
por ejemplo en el museo seguimos
teniendo cualquier cantidad de jóvenes
que se acercan a la historia de eva
sobre todo por aquello que hizo en
solamente 7 años de vida política que es
ni más ni menos que transformar la vida
a los sectores populares de haber
politizado a las mujeres y permitirles
la posibilidad de elegir ser elegidas y
transformarse en ciudadanas y fortalecer
los sindicatos y las redes formales de
previsión y de seguridad social así como
también las redes informales a través de
la fundación eva perón y su llamada
ayuda social directa que permitió a
mujeres ancianos niños ya los
desposeídos poder vivir una vida digna
acceder a vacaciones acceder a una
vivienda propia verse de significados y
obviamente
reconocidos como sujetos de derecho
pleno ese legado de basile presente y
lleva ha transformado la historia y la
estructura social política económica y
social de la argentina para siempre